Now we talked about what the trusted
computing base has to do.
Whether we take the security
kernel approach or we don't but
we largely sort of focused
on what it has to do.
When we say revisiting assurance,
what we're really talking about
is how well does it do that?
As the example we used before,
somebody's trying to sell you
an operating system, which is as we said
is the defector trusted computing base.
And they're making all kinds of
claims about how trusted it is.
When we say we want to get a sense
of the level of assurance,
somebody has to sort of convince us.
So let's just sort of quickly
talk about a couple of sort of
ways in which assurance can be provided.
One thing they can do is saying
you know we did implement it is
a software system but we extensively,
thoroughly tested it.
So testing is normal testing.
You do it for right functionality,
things like that.
But there's also also pen testing or
penetration testing.
Penetration testing basically refers to
sort of you come with the adversarial
mindset, saying what vulnerabilities
can I discover in this system?
If you can, better is to actually
have a proof that cannot be refuted.
So you have a formal verification.
It's a theorem that we prove saying this
is what my system is supposed to do and
here you can check that it does
exactly that and nothing else.
Other things we can do is, you know,
some sort of a checking that developers
have actually implemented all
the requirements that we had.
And we talked about a bunch of different
functions that are trusted computing
base or have requirements for
a trusted computing base.
So, when it comes to assurance and
it comes to testing,
a word of caution here.
We should look into what exactly does
testing give us in terms of assurance.
So remember, testing is good for
showing that there is a problem.
Testing obviously cannot
demonstrate absence of a problem.
You can't say, well I ran all these
tests, so there are no problems.
Tests can only demonstrate
problems that you can find.
And the variety of testing,
the testing is something that we do
fairly frequently in the software
development process, in the QA process,
Quality Assessment process.
And one kind of testing, for example,
is regression testing that
says when we enhance a system,
add features to it, patch it, well it's
a new system, it's a different system.
So regression testing says, you run
the test that we have to make sure that
these alterations that we did or
these changes that you made
don't break functionality or
it could improve performance.
However, the key take away from here is
really the first two bullets which is
testing is important.
It's useful to discover problems.
If you've done a lot of testing,
it increases your level of assurance or
confidence, but
of course it doesn't guarantee that
there are no more problems that
may be left with the system.